jostling and pushing all in the name of
science in today's experiment at an
empty exhibition hall this crowd remains
relatively calm but the same situation
at a football stadium or concert can
quickly become life-threatening
in panicked crowds bottlenecks can
become a killing zone where people are
literally crushed to death the goal of
this study at units research center is
to help prevent potential tragedies
Gabbidon in plate bazi and the moscow
project we work together with fire
departments police and security services
to discover more about how we can
improve safety at major events whose
fans travel episome come around 700 test
subjects are taking part in the project
cameras document exactly how people
behave in crowds each participants wears
a hat bearing a bar code allowing the
researchers to track each individual one
important experiment is finding out how
long paramedics need to make their way
through the crowd
mr. Holmes we provide this data to other
researchers all over the world anyone
can access it it's on our website there
you can watch the video footage and
download the paths people took turn be
expanded it's often all three
dimensional we're very glad to how about
researchers who want to use our data to
improve their own approach enzyme of the
storm el dia que pasa to focus on the
scientists perform experiments in
football stadiums trade fairs and
pedestrian zones constricted areas are
marked in red the computers collate the
information and identify potentially
dangerous locations the results have
provided some key insights for example
the larger the crowd the more restricted
the choice of an individual if panic
broke out right now many people would
have problems with orientation only
clearly marked signs can help prevent
chaos the Gita answer this person in a
moving stream of people is an individual
who hasn't coordinated their actions
with the others in a sense everyone goes
with the flow so if the crowd isn't able
to develop the intelligence to find the
best solution to a problem we have to do
more to induce it from the outside Dhaka
ended see other then the researchers
discover something new in this
experiment they've placed a pillar in
the middle of the room it simulates a
situation similar to a traffic
intersection it's a kind of roundabout
like those found in many European cities
they're astonished at how the crowd
participants react say brushing up on
one's body I couldn't missing a pillar
actually help the situation even though
putting it there meant less space for
the people in the intersection it's
still help prevent congestion you could
really confirm the results visual leave
now we have to quantify the data to be
able to say what will happen when a
crowd is moving at a certain speed or
has a certain density by the atique
that'll take six months also the things
that we just saw we're very interesting
dr. Farbin on my tail
the scientists at the eulogy Center have
been studying crowd behavior for 10
years now their results have contributed
significantly to preventing potential
catastrophes at football matches and
other huge events